no no it's funny i couldn't talk about
it you know i i've
i've now found someone who's
extraordinary uh
my wife now but you know we we were
young you know these things happen and
uh yeah you know and uh and you move on
i mean it's gotta be the worst though i
always think you know the reason i'm not
married
a lot of people go why are you married
you're 48 dude i'm like
well have you met my family
i'm like you know i love my family but i
look around me and if there's
dysfunction and then there's divorce and
there's a
i'm like i'm not doing that unless i
know it's right so
uh you know it sounds like you obviously
came from a good family and you had this
bonding experience for years and years
and when you were getting married it
felt like i mean i read that you you uh
you guys uh
eloped and went to yeah and just to the
bahamas and then
we actually yeah and honeymoon in cuba
but you know
yeah it was it was it was it was
difficult you know i had my issues
you know she had our issues uh it's yeah
it's
you know competition enters
uh uh the marriage a bit always um
it's difficult it's it was a very
divorce
is probably one of the most difficult
experiences i i i
went through yeah in my life absolutely
extremely difficult
see that's why i don't know if i want to
do that because
i know i i understand but i think you
know as you get older
you actually gain more experience and
you know
you suddenly know you don't always know
when you're younger what's right for you
you know and i think as you get older
you realize
uh you know you you get rid of the
things you don't want
and you keep the things you want you
know and that's what getting older is
you start caring less
about the and you start caring
more about what's important
and you'll when you meet that person who
is completely in tune with you
is you know incredibly supportive
smart funny intelligent yeah there are
people out there you have to have
all of those that seems like it's asking
a lot
beautiful educated i mean you know
they're just like you know it's like i'm
not all those things so why
why no yeah you are you of course you
are
it's you know my wife
ali alicia has taught me
so much literally more than
anyone else in my life about
relationships she really
is so extraordinarily
i mean she has such an extraordinary
sense of sense of self
and confidence and i think that was
given to her by her parents and her
upbringing
in australia and and so
she yeah taught me so much about you
know
uh listening is because that's something
i was not very good at
about compromise you know it's very
difficult to be in a relationship
it is you know however much you love you
know we love each other like crazy
we're literally joined at the hip and
actually this
pandemic has made us way closer
well i would crazy i'm crazy about her
i really am it but in in in the deepest
possible way
she's my she's my she's my girl
you know you're emotional it makes me it
makes me really emotional because we're
joined
at the hip and nothing could break that
and you know
and and this pandemic has made it
stronger yeah
and i learned so much from her and you
know i
she must have done something for me but
i learned so much
and i made so many mistakes sure
when i was younger and that is what life
is
you know yeah some people are like i
don't want to age
what age brings is that doesn't it
it brings that wonderful level of
experience where you
feel more secure about yourself
and you start caring less about what's
you know i keep thinking about that i
keep thinking that i'm slowly i
see that happening with me that i'm
starting to
just be a little more at times i see it
like
okay this is good this is new you like
this is a
it's a nuance don't don't get cocky it's
just a little thing here but
you know you're kind of a little bit
more relaxed with this situation you're
not freaking out you're not
and my uh one of my therapists said
something he goes
you know michael i i love this little
guy he was like dr
kessler tesla tesla yeah i loved him so
much i forgot his name
but as he said he said michael when
i really believe if when you fall in
love with someone and you
allow them to love you it's going to be
very tough when you could really really
allow
i think you're gonna soar i think you're
gonna really and i go
i didn't understand that and do you feel
like
when you have what is it about love what
is it about
it may sound corny but what is it about
a connection joined at the hip these
sort of phrases these sort of ideas that
makes you a
better person and makes you sore do you
think that's true and
that it does that i think it's
absolutely
one thousand percent true you know i
think
first of all it's it's support and trust
and and family you know in the
in the great sense of family you create
your new family you know i'm spending
more time with my wife than i ever spent
with my family
you know post leaving at 18.
uh it really yeah being with
ali i you know it took me a few years i
was still my
own demonic self you know after my
marriage i went through a period of
uh very self-destructed period of you
know
being single and being
yeah you know sort of uh
uh you just didn't love yourself
yeah yeah and i i went through a period
of kind of a dark period and
and ali i met ali before we were
together we knew each other for six
years but when i met her
i was like this girl is the one
that's the one but you know i wasn't
ready she was she suddenly was like
stay away from me you're a bad boy
you're in trouble
and you know the first few years of our
relationship
i really had to learn a lot i had to
learn to compromise a lot
compromise is actually a beautiful thing
it really enables you to
listen to to listen
to to yourself in a way and to listen to
your partner which is one of the most
important things there is
but i do believe that a partnership and
you know then love becomes
love is always there it just it sort of
transforms itself into something
deeper there's love there's that oh my
god
consuming love and sex and everything
which is
fantastic and then it transforms into
something
so deep